[Music]
what are the odds news submitter bike
did I make it yes you [ __ ] did yes
you done a man is convicted of rape a
after ironically being put in same
prison cell as his former victim why the
guards being so mean didn't know so
there was a [ __ ] up coincidence
yeah so huge assume that he's like you
ready for round two that's what Oh
dude can you imagine I got butt raped
into jail times and then I finally felt
relief because this guy disappeared and
then he came back and he's like hello
remember me every night so how did this
happen this man his name is Gary
Mottershead is he the receptacle or is
he the device so you the rapist okay the
device guy he's the plug he's 50 years
old now and so he was arrested on
suspicion of assaulting his wife back in
2006 guys [ __ ] raping everybody is a
he you know weird twist of fate he was
put in the exact same cell where his
victim who is now 43 was being held for
burglary so the victim is claiming that
Gary abused him between 1981 and 1983
and so at that time the victim was six
years old and Gary was 13 no he's
probably the reason why he's a burglar
now yeah so then that's why like now he
got arrested he's been jailed he got
convicted one count of rape and six
counts of sexual assault on a male under
the age of 13 he's denying all of this
though but the victim like after you
know providing the dates and like his
experience the judge that he determined
that like you know he did you know what
I gave this fool the better for the
doubt and I thought he was like Dexter
for booty ho like he was raping
injustice in in jail yeah like just you
[ __ ] guys in the ass that are [ __ ]
rapist themselves that exists in jail
yeah that's what I thought was happening
but apparently she's a [ __ ] raper
regular he's a regular rapist he's just
some kind of crazy guy that enjoys
raping for like a hobby which is really
wrong he was the victims babysitter
like the victim the male victim and his
sister and so it would what Gary would
do is that he would give the little boy
alcohol and then send a little girl up
to her room and tell the little boy if
you ever tell anyone what I'm doing to
you I'm gonna hurt your sister
he chose the boy instead of the girl
yeah yeah people are crazy
Wow he was like 15 15 wow I mean when I
was 15 I don't think I ever found kids
hot I always wanted a college girl so I
was a reverse pedophile dude well I
hated kids I hated the way they smell
the way they spoke when they're always
around you and [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here laughs when he sees a onesie he
thinks it's like lingerie [ __ ] it's like
Victoria's Secret like God damns
yeah onesie over there yeah I think
that's how his mind works he's [ __ ]
crazy dude kids stink I know I mean they
got that'sthat's pit asphalt no you know
I mean yeah you're not talking about
right he's had an odor it smells like
the McDonald's playpen
oh yeah right when they come home did
you smell of sweat yeah I think recently
started smelling like that that's it man
smell couple months or maybe even a year
like he just started smelling coming
home like baby you gotta take a shower
immediately he just smelled like
perspiration and heat like Sun hid his
clothes for like eight hours get the
[ __ ] away from me why do you smoke a
tetherball yeah and those little girls
think - they all [ __ ] grimy help
touching all the boys to piss me off man
I hate the Lincoln smell man
and they worse not touch a face and [ __ ]
hey [ __ ] out here so that happens to you
a lot will because I worked at a church
so these kids just so sweaty and [ __ ]
dude they're all catching colds and [ __ ]
and they're making you catch a cold and
they [ __ ] sneeze into your mouth yeah
while you're speaking that rapist she
looks like he knew he did wrong it's
actually a father of boring oh my god he
raped those kids too it's
he looks like he rapes like on a regular
like if you look at mug shots of have
you found this man or whatever like this
is that stereotypical look in his face
says yes I rape this fool is a [ __ ]
tormented life man like his brain must
be all [ __ ] up they're saying like
because of that abuse the victim he
ended up going up to be in trouble a lot
like he didn't even really finish school
like he would constantly be going into
jail like he would just have a troubled
life that's so sad so they got they were
put in the same cell yeah but they
didn't know oh because initially the
victim didn't really recognize them good
there were kids
he's not gonna recognize them cuz he was
a little boy is he hitting on him I'm
not sure I'm not sure how he was able to
like figure it out but eventually the
victim was like wait that you were the
one that did it so this did he rape them
back dad see I was gonna say that that
would be a perfect opportunity do you
think he could have raped like can you
get your dick up though like boy I mean
he started raping - right no he must
already know he was just a burglar yeah
he started stealing okay he was more
productive about his trauma you know
it's more positive like you don't go
because you got raped you don't go out
rape other people you just steal okay
that's different no one it's a
victimless crime you know what I mean
what are you talking about all the
victims I got they're okay but things
can't be replaced
alright he's not he's not it's not with
innocence he's not stealing photos and
irreplaceable
a phone has a bunch of photos lots of
cat photos think he'd this guy what he
stole was VCRs and [ __ ] but if he was a
heart stealer Oh
[Laughter]
I'm imagining that this guy stole VCRs
okay what the who the [ __ ] on the VCR
Joe like he's old the guy what hell does
he know he yeah but he went to jail
a long time ago oh man what time did he
go wouldn't he go Joe why your voice I
think it's not screaming low too much my
boys going out all right let's just say
he stole VCRs and Walkmans all right it
was a victimless crime because people
were able to just buy another one he
stole from the rich all right so he
changed his life and he says I got raped
but I'm not gonna rape other people I'm
gonna just steal it was messed up about
prison I watched too much like TV shows
everything that's the problem it's like
I don't know what the true etiquette is
when you go to prison cuz we kind of
like television I think that when I get
there I have to get my lunch trained
right I have to go to the biggest guy I
had to smash my lunch tray against his
head now I don't think that's what
you're supposed to do but because I want
so much TV I'm almost a thousand percent
sure that's what I'm gonna do yeah and
you're gonna get murdered and then when
I get stabbed up and I'm in the hospital
what are you supposed to do what is he
Attica
there are books from like former FBI CIA
agents or whatever that had to go to
jail because they did the crime while
they were like Oh undercover
yeah well no they went into jail because
they actually did crime oh yeah and then
they had to survive in there it's very
interesting people yeah but it's so many
good stories man there is one guy that
made it in with the Mafia and he says
that the first time he came in he was he
was shittin bricks he came from the
straight and narrow world I think he
embezzled money or something I'd be
scared if I was going to be going to
prison and stuff like let's say like
that whole judicial process is gonna
take like a year or two you best believe
I'm doing BJJ Muay Thai I'm trading my
[ __ ] ass off David who are you
playing right now
what a pudding though is different
though I'm going to prison David I
already know what it's gonna happen okay
oh you know me so well you're gonna show
us all the [ __ ] YouTube videos you're
gonna find the top notch [ __ ]
instructor you're gonna get all your
[ __ ] gear you're gonna go the first
impact and then the next seeker break
I'm so sore and then you're never gonna
go back but this is different
I'm gonna get butt-fucked in prison but
this is freedom right now I don't have
to get buck-buck my buttholes fine now
when my buttholes in danger it's
different it's like the pufferfish the
cup cutie is boy what he's into shut the
[ __ ] up you're gonna be in a [ __ ]
pink bikini in prison oh yeah fine I'm
gonna present to Marla some beauty cakes
I thought you was mad funny being
Instagram ho yeah I like what you did to
those boxers Maji no [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I'm a snap [ __ ] necks oh man I can
not get that image of you out of my head
too late you're welcome because I'm
trying to show people how beautiful I
think I would die if I ever went to I'm
such a [ __ ] I don't even know what lady
prison is like or just a new black I
couldn't watch that it's just a lot of
lesbians a lot of like [ __ ] eating it
[ __ ] yeah I'm yeah I'm dead I don't know
I'm gonna do that whole expedited like
two years thing where you're gonna learn
martial arts to the [ __ ] max no I'm
real with myself so what would you do
what would you do that I'm dead serious
though like you have to go to jail today
yeah yeah if you have to go to jail in
here you know you're going in a year
what would you do dude [ __ ] eat at it
off like crazy I'm gonna look aggressive
as [ __ ] I'm gonna follow my [ __ ] pee
on the road and come back you were to
come back out it'll be so funny you're
gonna look like the toughest one there
right and a new inmates gonna come
thinking that like the David method yeah
and she's gonna want to fight you
because you look like the toughest one
and you're like oh [ __ ] your ass up
why didn't get to finish my plan I'm
gonna train [ __ ] hard you should be
doing I'm gonna get Jack them down
steroids
oh man I'm honest do that instead of the
other thing yeah
she's my point I haven't David when
you're the toughest guy in prison and
someone comes over and hits you over the
head with a lunch tray because they
think they got a beat you now oh [ __ ] I
don't even think about that but yeah
hopefully I'll be out by that years and
how come none of you guys thought about
fleeing the country I wanted to say that
I'm like no no you have to go to prison
like that's the that's the thing so if
you have to go what would you do
you guys are missing the whole point
I'll learn how to [ __ ] on command
I don't [ __ ] learn how to throw that
[ __ ] out of my butthole that means
you're you eat a lot so if as soon as I
[ __ ] bend over all right big boy
ain't no [ __ ] oh he was like this
brat he just go then he deserves it some
of those dudes in them they don't feel
like they get [ __ ] no get them at it
don't [ __ ] a man right like you get jail
yeah I just like booyah [ __ ] you don't
know I think we're being a little too
negative here okay one hour [ __ ]
stretch now we can hide [ __ ] - or a
stretch in our strange shape it is but
you it's not a useful shape yeah but we
could we could it's it's loose now so I
could hide things if I need to hide some
cigarettes cards okay I could hide go to
jail how about a car yeah
but but the but the other thing is it
feels great to be appreciated
[Music]